[Applause]
trash talking pop-offs key charging
rejecting handshakes or forcing one
these gestures can sometimes be used as
a strategy distracting their opponents
and making them lose their focus in the
game
some players are just doing it for fun
and to others well it's a personal thing
regardless these moments can add hype to
the crowd which makes tournaments more
exciting and entertaining
right now this video is a compilation of
disrespectful moments in tekken
tournaments
hey i'm drew and you're watching ochoto
tv
i've won more tournaments than you'll
ever enter
[Applause]
oh no we can hear bronson again bronson
again no headphones
yo bronzer trying to talk him out of
wearing the headphones oh get the sweep
again
all right all right
this time he finished the down two two
wasn't even counter in there looking to
close it out here nice glock on the rage
drive no i got you read my lip i got you
oh man oh wow
man this old man he's got a little fight
in him
he does
he is just a boy
he's still learning
i hope everyone in the street is
watching right
man that's not cool man
looks like great
can we pick stages no hey random collect
oh you hear me
oh no oh no it's over now oh no
i got you don't don't fake it
this is where he feels really scary
because i mean he's been going for the
mid the whole time but he does have the
low available remember
he gets the rage drop off of the
sidewalk that might be enough to kill oh
up four four to take it that orbital
barbie towel
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow
that was big
not going to be able to kill great
positioning and momentum oh i got you
i like it i mean he was patient there
that was a very quick break from oh into
the range drive again oh my god with the
four three i got i know when i hit that
but i'm really nervous right now
all right all right just check it so
just letting you guys know yes i
understand there is a combo
but uh i'd rather play the mix-up game
at this point all right oh
oh here we go he cancels it this time he
goes
i got the combo
it might be premature celebration
oh set point right now
cheer for me chad
i don't think you'll be able to hear
them even if they do bronson so it's
okay i want chat on my screen right now
give me a cap when you're cheering for
me
someone cut off his bike
anyways here we go bronson
wow
and i just beat him wow such a nice guy
bronze tran isn't
sorry guys definitely deserve that win
and remember you guys are going to hear
a bronte japan if you're watching the
stream at home
is he is he creeping into the scene
dang with the 10 old sticker
oh oh that's guaranteed
no that's not good oh we got him
mommy kicks
so first round not looking good
he got me
nice
calm down calm down
get him oh get up don't break it four
[ __ ] control baby damage
he's pretty old man he can't be bothered
you better calm down oh man we got to
return you to the home in good shape but
we don't want them to come after us and
i think we should remind both of these
players that again this is good
shirt oh no
you
he hit the high though for sure that is
definitely his voice i cracked
now into a running power well i'm
looking to close it out with a perfect
baby down back to again
just in time
[Applause]
take off that shirt
wow sounding a little gross up there
does he want it i think he won okay
here's the pressure what's he going to
go for oh this is so scary
one round powerbomb all right what's he
gonna go for this time offense in his
[Applause]
[Music]
folks here nice
[Applause]
beautiful we're funnies
great damage that's the round perfectly
fine
sending the message early the twitch
chat is going crazy right now they hate
the keychart this is how you gotta play
okay okay nice adjustment michael
murray's figure
has blue but will he even get a chance
to use it he does not
hug every round no there was a wall
there
paul is always in the lead with the red
nice block and the punish
and the key charge bubble key charge
yeah we almost got two of them off
please is that this might be it
that's it
grounded damage and holding on that top
eight right now for real fighting for
his life against one of the best of all
time
almost let's go man i'll bell versus
jdcr let's get it oh he didn't confirm
the head okay a bell okay a bell
poke poke poke poke ends with a mid and
a key charge oh
we saw some bad things happened
yesterday when the players did their
chance there we go
having the lead now this is huge all
right that range has been a huge factor
so far in this set give me my space plus
reigns i'm gonna take those lows i'm
gonna take it let's go down for a woman
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
he's going to send him to the sky
one
oh
he doesn't even want to show it at jdcr
2-1
oh
the maestro
the hard read without
oh
[Music]
yeah dude
scary man that was impressive that was
the best considering how badly
photographed beat bab earlier
oh my god
john didn't know
john john
this is about to get good
oh let's go
[Applause]
beautiful
oh wait he might have dropped that he
dropped him he was looking at him he was
looking at him while he dropped a combo
oh my god that's why you don't do that
that's why you don't do that
oh i'll kick this hey is he gonna look
at him again he's gonna look at the
screen
oh my god he dropped the ender again
he was looking at the screen that time
oh
no
and it's gonna be two rounds straight
for john thinks that both of them should
have been [ __ ] up
wow
wow
something started oh no one was gonna
kill him oh he's gonna kill he's gonna
kill oh he's looking right back at him
now
he cracked johnny with a smile he had a
crack oh especially get up no
big launcher he's not dead but no it's
not it's uh this is a bad situation to
be in right now range mode shopping a
good thing
oh not like that is not
and john ding
gonna eliminate polka from the
tournament man oh man
[Music]
and he's gonna have to test it right
he's gonna have to test it we know we've
seen him play
earlier what are you doing what are you
doing oh he's joining that you're
showing the uh the cucumber cosplay oh
damn oh look at pokemon
god kokoba is
he's limited he's like i can't believe
you exposed me
on stream like that go inside
yeah i'm not i'm not gonna say the magic
three-letter word that everyone likes to
hear on stream but man that was wrong
are working for him you guys posted by
me you have to have to shave on man
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's get a
and
he's like oh i can't believe you've done
this
twice to me
dad the repeat
but now
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning
[Applause]
foreign
oh
thanks for watching and be sure to
subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
you